american women owe much of their legal
protection from discrimination to ruth
bader ginsburg
many years of work before she became a
judge she was a gender equality pioneer
and an architect of women's right
movement as a litigator she led the
supreme court to completely change how
it viewed discrimination against women
on the basis of sex
paula reed looks at ginberg's towering
legal influence
paula good to see you listen she was
tiny in stature but she was so mighty
when it came to influence
good morning gail mighty indeed even
before she was a justice
attorney ruth bader ginsburg had already
made an indelible
mark in the fight for equal treatment
for women
she was one of the founding members of
the aclu's women's rights project
and while she was there she came up with
creative avenues
to secure more rights for women and also
try to move the country closer to a
system where all people
are treated equally under the law she
has compiled a truly historic record of
achievement
even before ruth bader ginsburg was
nominated to the supreme court in 1993
she had already cemented her place in
history
women today face discrimination in
employment
ginsburg argued six cases before the
supreme court in the 1970s
winning five of them the supreme court
today ruled unanimously that a widower
with children is entitled to the same
social security benefits a widow would
receive
often securing rights for women by
representing men
being discriminated against in similar
ways law professor margot schlanger
clerked for ginsburg during her first
two years on the court
can you point to specific rights that
you and i have
because of justice ginsburg yes
absolutely
there was a time when women couldn't own
their own credit card
when women couldn't didn't have the
right to
equal treatment in in state-sponsored
jobs
during her first term ginsburg wrote a
concurring opinion in a sexual
harassment case
that went farther than her colleagues
arguing conduct
is illegal if it unreasonably interfered
with the plaintiff's work performance
she understood way before me too
that avoiding uh sexual harassment
in the workplace is a matter of equality
not just of avoiding boorish behavior
that desire to fight for equal justice
led her to a career centered around the
fight to make the country
live up to its founding ideals think
back
to 1787 who were
we the people who were they
they certainly weren't women the genius
of the united states and our
constitution
is that over now more than 200 sometimes
turbulent
years yeah that we has expanded
and expanded once she was on the bench
her fight for equality continued with
landmark opinions
opening all male schools to women and
expanding protections for the disabled
ginsburg was only the second civil
rights attorney to ascend to the bench
and she ultimately attained this
cultural icon status
i've been reporting here all weekend at
the court and i have seen
hundreds of people coming here wearing
t-shirts with
her face on them so many people coming
here this weekend to pay respects for a
woman who expanded freedoms
for so many tony what a beautiful story
paula and it's a great way to remember
her life as forever expanding the
definition of
we in the united states of america
thanks paula tony i just ordered an
rbg bathing suit think of that they make
those
yes they do where is your face on your
body all over
oh okay very cute very cute all right we
look forward to that next summer i guess
maybe i'm not ever going to show it i'm
just letting you know it's out there i
don't know
stay tuned to instagram